thank you ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this
central planning area planning committee
on the 27th of january
my name is councillor jeannette stiltz
and i am the chairman of the committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few house copy
keeping rules to run through
members the setup for this evening has
been designed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocols agreed at council on
the 29th of april 2021 in the interest
of member and officer
safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up and indicate if
you wish to speak and then i will invite
you to an appropriate time
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone
and
speak clearly
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and ensure your
micro funds remain off when not speaking
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda paper regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind the top table
apologies for absence miss bird do i
have any apologies for absence
thank you item three on the agenda
it is recommended that the minutes of
the eye
of the meeting held on the 15th of
december found on pages 7 to 10 are
approved as true and accurate do i have
a seconder councillor maze thank you
are you all happy to take these minutes
as
uh consent
thank you
item 4 on the agenda is declarations of
interest to discuss the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other peculiar interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda have in regards to paragraph 628
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting do i
have any declarations of interest
no lovely thank you we'll move on item 5
on the agenda is
land west of south bank cromwell hill
this is found on pages 11-36
miss matthews would you like to present
that
agenda item
thank you chairman can you hear me come
on
yeah okay
um so this is an application for a
single-story three-bedroom dwelling
on the site hatched in red on that slide
which is south of cromwell
um
lane in malden the reason why this
application is coming to committee is
because it is a departure to the current
local plan even though
plan permission has been approved in the
past and for the same proposal um but
that previous plan permission has now
expired and therefore it needs to come
back to committee
if the application is going to be
approved
again another location plan
so as i said before it's outside the
development boundary
but there are dwellings opposite and to
the east and west of the site
the site is within the malden
conservation area the approximate
position of the application site is
indicated with the red arrows so it's
within the chelmar and blackwater
navigation conservation area and
adjacent to the malden conservation area
and this is a proposed block plan
and it shows the new dwelling towards
the northern end of the site
shows new access in the north
eastern corner of the site
um and the site is um sloping we'll show
some cross sections um shortly but
the the top of the site the northern end
of the site is quite a lot lower than
the southern boundary of the site
um
okay
so these are some proposed elevations
and you can see that the dwelling will
be very low profile
um
and partly below ground is viewed from
from one lane
and again single story
some side elevations
east and west
um what's that
this is a floor plan
against single story
rectangular shape
you'd have a sedum roof
flat roof hidden roof
and these are some cross sections so the
um the dot the dotted line along here
shows um existing ground levels and then
the thicker black line shows the
proposed ground levels
and the top one is close to two and the
bottom one shows the whole of the site
and shows the difference in ground
levels between and as i said the the
southern boundary which is higher than
the northern boundary
street scenes existing and proposed and
this property
referred to on available your papers um
as
the adjoining site and no recent
commission and again that was outside
the development boundary
and they're review showing the um
application site which is in this area
here
and then we've got some um photos of the
site views from cromwell lane looking
south to that up toward up
from the lower end of the site up
towards the higher end of the thing
and some a couple of views along
cromwell lane
and
just to put it in its uh
context
in terms of parking i've been asked to
mention that
electric charging points aren't included
as part of the application but there is
a condition um recommended that would
require those um that to be provided in
details to be agreed
um
before
the dwelling is occupied
and on that and on the basis of the the
um
the site being
very close to malden town center and in
being a sustainable location
and the
the the lack of harm to the character
appearance of the area and the
conservation area
and as the proposal complied with all
the relevant standards in terms of
parking and
private meaning space it's recommended
that the application is approved subject
to the conditions set out in your papers
thank you
thank you for that miss matthews we have
a public participant for this planning
application we have the agent mr jackson
in line with public participation scheme
i now invite them to read out their
submission mr jackson you will have two
minutes to
read out yours
submission
can we take the
slides off so we can see mr jackson
thank you
so thank you mr jackson you can you've
now got two minutes
thank you chairman good evening members
not a pretty site on your screen i guess
i am a chartered town planner and i am
instructed by mrs peter and ben hemsley
the applicants and owners in this matter
the proposal is to erect a three-bedroom
bungalow atlanta joining cromwell lane
malden
the scientists have field situations
between the residential properties on
billy road and cromwell lane
the bungalow is proposed to be set back
from the road the dwelling is to be
constructed with flat
flat sedum roof stone walling the cedar
boarding and render
the height of the dwelling is proposed
to be 2.3 meters
the proposal is identical to that
granted planning permission in 2014 by
the central area planning committee
the site lies in the children blackwater
navigation conservation area and joins
the moulding conservation area
the proposal is supported by a heritage
statement and the heritage and
conservation officer confirms that as
the house will be sunk into the ground
and have a flat sedum roof its visual
impact upon the two conservation areas
at this particular location will be
limited
the design is thoughtful and proposes
quality materials
as such the officer advises the council
that there will be no harm to the
character or appearance of either
conservation areas
whilst the proposal dwelling is outside
of the settlement boundary for malden it
is considered to be in a sustainable
location
the contribution towards the essex codes
to rams has been paid and the applicants
have agreed to the pre-commencement
conditions referred to
pages 29-33 of your officer report
thank you for your time this evening
thank you mr johnson oh sorry
um
members i now invite you to
open up the questions counsellor nun
yes thank you um whilst i'm really
pleased that this is a low-profile
building it is in a very sensitive
potentially sensitive area
archaeologically
potentially it's part of the the site of
the ramparts of the anglo-saxon bur
i noticed that um
the low-lying nature will mean
excavation
and i notice also that there are
suggested archaeological conditions
and i think if we do go ahead with this
um
this application that the
archaeological conditions should be
adhered to should be met and should be
uh
enforced as a condition thank you thank
you miss matthews did you want to
um through chairman the um
the conditions that are recommended are
on the basis of the advice from the
specialists at besses county council and
they're very standard conditions um
and they do require that the
archaeological archaeology um of the
site is investigated and dealt with
before any works in in relation to the
new dwelling um commenced and the agent
applicant has agreed to that so on that
basis there's no reason to um
suspect that their conditions won't
won't be complied with and if they're
not then there's the usual enforcement
investigation and powers to remedy
um
and
require the um or ensure the condition
is complied within the usual way thank
you
thank you um enforcement's difficult
isn't it once uh an archaeological
site's been destroyed but uh let's hope
it doesn't come to that uh i say that we
we very uh forcefully
apply the condition
thank you
any other questions remembers
council swain
thank you chairman yes first of all i
have a few little points which um miss
matthews can probably dismiss fairly
quickly and then one or two observations
on the application first of all
um
question of the displays on the entrance
which need to be sufficiently wide to
allow traffic to particularly
construction traffic to get in and off
of some narrow lane
um
the second thing is about this excavated
material it is said that it um will be
retained on site um since it's so much i
i wonder whether the
way it is disposed of on-site
um should be monitored uh particularly
for questions of stability it looks from
the
drawings as though the excavated
material is going to be pulled forward
onto the hillside
and
it's been quite a large volume of it
and
i assume and it's a matter of building
regulations and architecture that the
roof which is a large area
is capable of taking
such a green
roof
display and and the other thing is about
daylight i mean this is very enclosed
around
and has uh
relatively i know it's got a lot of
glass front
um
there's fairly limited glazing otherwise
i i don't know whether the amount of
daylight is a
is a consideration or whether that is
solely between the
the owner and the architect
and on the actual reasoning for it um
[Music]
this this and a similar um application
has been considered in the past
um and i i find the
the few arguments were were raised
um against uh the
plans was rather weak
and
the
argument about five-year land supply i
don't give much credit to when you talk
about an individual application
um but
another puzzle that is not within the
settlement boundary of
malden and maybe that is something that
may change
um
as for views across from the other side
um
particularly at the moment one notices
houses populated all across the hillside
so i don't think it's going to make any
difference and because of its low
um profile um it's not going to
obtrude at all i don't think as far as
views across
the background are concerned so
um i don't see any reason to um oppose
the application thank you uh miss
matthews would you like to answer any of
councillor swains um other than
yes i'll
respond as best i can to the
issues that have been raised in terms of
visibility space
essex county council haven't recommended
any minimums um i suspect that's
primarily on the basis that it's a
private and adopted road
and it's not anything they have
jurisdiction over
um
it could be
and the details that have been submitted
in terms of the access
are fairly limited um that's although
there would be
so if if that is a concern of members
that
could put an extra condition on asking
for
details of that entrance way and the
visibility displays um
or hopefully would address that concern
about um
access
although not normally something we would
put on
um
where it's a private
access way and in a made private way but
that is possible and in terms of um
spoil
and there's no suggestion that there be
any need to take any spoil off the site
and it would all be redistributed within
the site
and stability of the land would would
primarily be um an issue for um
building regulations um
and the other point to mention is that
in the conditions there is a condition
asking for um some final details of
ground levels and finish floor levels
and just to make sure that
things don't change um from what have
been proposed once they've worked up
their
their detailed drawings and the um
or for building regulations so there is
that that sort of um protection there in
terms of
spoil moving and ground level changes
um
the the strength of the roof would be um
in terms of being able to to support the
weight of the sedan roof would be a
building control
matter
and in terms of daylight into the house
um
it perhaps a matter of opinion but but
that's the front elevation there's quite
a few windows there and remember it's
only a single story property so um
and at the back again there's
um quite a large area of glazing
and the windows on the front would have
a an aspect an outlook over
over the lane and and beyond um those at
the back would have a limited
view but there would be um
an outlook and there is space
um
there's like a courtyard area and being
created at the back
and so
there would be um
there would be an outlook and and access
to light coming into those windows
um
and in terms of the um position of the
development barrier i wasn't quite sure
whether
you were surprised that it wasn't within
the development boundary or whether you
were surprised that it would be
recommended for approval um even though
it was outside the development boundary
um but nobody to know it's not within
the development boundary whether that
will change in the future that's that's
a matter for the
um the policy team and as part of any
local plan review
um but it is outside
all bit just outside and um
in those scenarios the council is
required to assess the
sustainability of the site um
and in some cases rules sites like this
are considered to be unacceptable
because the people who would be living
in the on the on the dwelling would need
to
um rely on private vehicles to get to
the day-to-day services but in this case
um the occupiers of site will be able to
walk um to quite a large number of
services facilities both
and as said in the report and both
within the um
town centre and also there's the retail
park and
and there's employment opportunities
down on on the fall bridge for example
so
in terms of
accessibility and sustainable location
then this site is considered to be
quite good in in that respect thank you
thank you
you can come back and then i'll go to
council shaunicy and councillor lagan
you can come back council sorry
yes thank you
um ms matthews and yes my concern with
the soil was the large volume um
would not necessarily be compacted and
uh therefore would be in danger of
sliding down the hillside
um as far as the light is concerned i
would point out this is basically north
facing
and the south facing side with the
windows of course are largely
um
what should say obscured from sunlight
because of being on the downslope
of a hill and
recessed into the ground
um
and on the question of the settlement um
definition i i mean that there are a
number of
uh buildings
and houses further along the road
than this one so
that doesn't seem to be much of an
argument now
thank you thank you
councillor sean say
thank you
do you want to turn your mic on council
assurances
thank you good idea that oh
yeah thank you um
i apologize to ms matthews if she
already uh mentioned this but they there
are roof lights too on the um building
um which will um you know aid the light
um i'd like to um concur with councillor
nunn re the archaeological conditions i
think they're most important
um on this site
and and can't be emphasized enough
um and me being me i would like as much
ecology on the site retained um now i
understand ms matthews that one of the
hedgerows
is is going to be retained and and
and mustn't be um
damaged or taken up
um i i saw that in the um text somewhere
um
but as this is a large site um i think
that um i mean obviously it needs
tidying up because it's in a bit of a
state at the moment i don't expect them
to leave it as it is
but i would like the owners to be really
careful at what they take out and what
they leave
as far as the ecology of the site is
concerned
thank you chair thank you miss matthews
did you want to
and perhaps thank you chairman and just
to mention that there are conditions
well the application came in with the
ecology report and with suggestions and
mitigation included within that um which
is conditioned number 11 requires that
there was to be carried out in
accordance with that and that's
something that the essex county council
ecology team have advised um is
satisfactory and um
and there is also another condition
asking for diabet biodiversity
enhancement strategy to be submitted as
well so
not only will they be um protecting
existing ecology um as far as they can
but there will be required to enhance it
and those details would be need to come
in and
be approved
um
as
in writing by the local authority in the
normal way
but um so in terms of ecology um
that this the proposal complies with
what we would normally expect thank you
okay
okay
council alone
yeah thanks cheers sort of comments and
observations really i think i can
go with council shawnee council and what
council swain said about uh ecology
archaeology and also the access um view
and me being me i'd probably never want
to see another piece of our
much diminishing green land in the town
put on to disappear but um this is a
lawful application um and it's a big old
block let's let's make no means about it
but the visual impact um the way that
the
applicants have have designed it to
mitigate um is is somewhat pleasing
um
i struggle with this this thing about
sustainability because
yes it is in a sustainable location but
what stream you know comes to mind is
with like the
that the housing needs analysis one
minute we need more two bedrooms and we
need more or three bedrooms and it's
like a it's a moving feast isn't it uh
and this this building yes it's in an
area where it's quite it's close to you
know you turn left out of the lane and
you can go down the road and there's
there's a plethora of shops etc if you
turn right and you have to go up market
hill as people get older in this this
residence they are going to be needing
more more use of vehicles because
they're not going to be able to walk up
market hill to go to iceland to lug down
there 25 pounds worth of shopping so i
think some of that needs to be
considered um and it falls within this
thing about sustainability and i know
it's allowed but it's just an area that
concerns me
um i'm also concerned like councillor
swain said about the access because
there's a very much loved and well used
business up at the end of cromwell lane
so the more
visual
safety sort of scope we can give to
driving in and driving out i think is
absolutely critical because it's used by
pedestrians as well as people driving
down to that that wonderful business
um so they're they're more comments than
than
observations more than anything else but
uh also a concern for the safety of of
people using the lane
thank you thank you
miss mathias
i don't think that there's any more i
can add to what i've already said in
terms of those issues
yeah so we can condition to look at i
don't know the planning terminology you
called it a
when you have the more of an access way
visibility display
that thing there yeah yeah and three
item what i was suggesting was that we
could um
oh somebody's have we got too many
speakers open
what's making funny knives
okay um
then yeah so i was what i was suggesting
was to have a condition requiring
details of that access point to be
submitted for approval and that would
include the visibility displays and and
surfacing um
and yeah so
yeah so that that was what i was
suggesting that at the moment the
details are quite
um
unclear so and the condition would ask
for um a bigger scale drawing and just
of the access point so that to make sure
that
um it was going to be
safe as it could be okay
councillor lachlan would you like to
uh propose a condition on that access
point
which then we could take what i would
like to propose and i think i'll call
for miss matthews through the chair to
help me with the right wording is
basically what what ms matthews has just
said that a condition
is applied
with regard to submission of
visuals is it splay
is that's the one i'm a good venture
with us thank you visibility displays um
to be submitted
or for review and assessment based on
safety grounds
if that's acceptable
i mean i think that that is
quite possible i think the one thing i
would say is
at least taking from this block plan it
does appear to be
quite open um
yeah as a as sort of previously advised
you'll see the highway 40 doesn't
normally
delve into such matters
once it's off
the public network
um
i do appreciate your points about
um
members of the public using it as a
footway so obviously we want to make
sure we avoid
that uh any any potential collisions um
i mean i think it
it could be reasonable is it i don't
think it's
particularly
onerous um
yeah
i was just going to mention nothing i
think particularly in this case where
there is a public right-of-way public
footpath i think if it's just a private
access way
um
it might be a bit more questionable but
because there is an official public
right-of-way designated footpath which
runs right across the frontage um then i
think there is more of a reason
more justification for
asking for these extra details um and
there's lots of extra other details that
they would need to submit for approval
anyway so it's um
it's a new dwelling rather than a house
extension for example so
as um my colleague said it i don't think
that would be onerous or certainly not
unreasonable in this case and um
something that as officers wouldn't
recommend against doing
counseling no thank you very much i
think i'm sure that the owners and the
agents would would look favorably on
providing the safest potential access
and egress to the property for the
occupiers and the public so that'll be
great thank you so if you're happy with
that condition i would need a seconder
on that condition councillor maze thank
you for seconding it before we move on
to any other proposals we would need to
vote on that condition going on to this
so
all members in favor of adding that
condition to this
application
thank you that's carried then
some members are there any other
questions on this application council
hubner
yeah um miss matthews uh mentioned evie
points
but i don't see it on a on the
proposal so
you comment on that
yes three chairman um
i i think um maybe i didn't explain very
well but um
what i was saying is they haven't shown
any eb um charging points so there is a
condition which requires them
to be
submitted and approved
along with various other details but
that is that issue is covered in the
conditions
just to bring to your attention it's
condition number five
are you happy with that thank you
do i have any other questions
like do i have a proposal or
counselor maize
at last we're getting an application
that actually cares about the
environment which i was quite impressed
with
thank you very much for conditioning for
an electric um vehicle charging point
i i actually propose that we accept this
with the conditions that are attached
and the additional condition that was
put forward by councillor lagan
do i have a seconder
i think you've got your hand up first
thank you i know thank you very much
so that we have had a proposal by
councillor maize it's been seconded by
councillor edwards all those in favor
that is carried
so thank you miss matthews
for that presentation
moving on to item six on the agenda any
other items of the business of business
the chairman decides are urgent there
isn't any item seven um
whilst i have been sharing these
meetings i have been vice chair
of this committee
so item seven is to appoint a chairman
of this committee and i call for a
nomination councillor nun uh nominate
councillor lagan thank you
councillor lagan
okay
do i have any other nominations
councillor mays
i would like to nominate councillor
stilts do i have a seconder
thank you
all right because councillor lagan's
nomination was first um recorded vote
please okay thank you councillor none
tara would you take the recorded vote
yes
i don't think you can stand for this
position because you are vice chairman
and if if you were to be elected you
would then be chair of vice chair which
i think is unbelievable no i would
i would have to then call for an
election of a vice chair no i think you
would have to you would have to give up
being vice chair before you could i am
quite happy to resign as vice chair and
i would anyway because if
you elect a new chairman i feel it's
only right that that chairman has a vice
chair so i will resign from this
position
you probably should have done that
before before okay well i'm quite happy
to stand down there
so
have you got any other person other than
council or lagging you would like to put
up councillor mays i i still nominate
councillor stilts
okay
thank you right katara would you like to
take a recorded vote
uh yes kevin i would sorry
i'm a little confused which is not
so you've resigned now
as vice chair
tara can you advise us on where we go
from here i have been nominated as
chair
although i am vice chair
is that able to be done
my understanding chairman is yes it is
and should you be elected as chairman
then we would just need to appoint a
vice chairman from within the committee
that's my understanding thank you
thank you so
tara would you like to take the vote
uh yes chairman um i would suggest if
it's the e if it's possible just to call
out members names and if they could
indicate if they're voting council lag
and council stilts or abstaining thank
you probably the easiest way if that's
okay with everyone so starting with
councillor miss field please
thank you council stilts
councillor stilts but you've missed
councillor nun and character
so the results of that are seven for
councillor lagoon three for councillor
stilts and no abstentions that is lovely
i will like to congratulate councillor
lagan on becoming chairman of this
committee
um congratulations councillor lagan you
now have to choose your vice chair
i don't know if well thank you for the
congratulations first of all i don't
do i do they have to be chair for the
next meeting
okay
at the next meeting you will have to
choose the vice chair
so i will close this meeting at
2004
thank you all for your contributions
this evening i know